hasta ahora hemos trabajado con enlaces
sencillos y anillos de carbono pero
pensemos qué pasaría si las cosas se
ponen un poco más complicadas así que
déjenme pintar una molécula aquí digamos
tenemos algo así no sé y podemos subir
un poco acá ok
ahí tenemos una molécula verdad entonces
esta cadena difiere de los casos
anteriores porque presenta
ramificaciones ya no es una cadena
simple verdad se ramifica así que vamos
a hallar la cadena más larga para poder
ponerle nombre a esta cadena y como
siempre lo central cuando queremos
nombrar una molécula es identificar
cadenas largas verdad es identificar
cuántos carbonos tenemos en nuestras
cadenas así que primero identificamos la
cadena más larga y por ejemplo si
nosotros empezáramos no sé aquí digamos
y recorremos digamos hacia esta parte
tendríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 carbonos
mientras que si empezamos de este otro
no tenemos 123456789 carbonos así que
aquí está nuestra cadena más larga ahí
la tienen esta es la cadena más larga y
que estoy poniendo con otro color
simplemente para que podamos distinguir
la entonces nuestra cadena más larga y
cuantos carbonos tienen esta cadena pues
tiene 123456789 carbonos verdad entonces
la cadena más larga consta de 9 carbonos
9 carbonos y por lo tanto esto va a
llevar un nombre de no nano verdad el
nano verdad va a tener por ahí el nombre
de no nano y recordemos que significan
una no pues justamente la terminación a
no significa que es un arcano y eso
implica que todos los enlaces son
simples no tenemos enlaces múltiples y
el non es el prefijo para 9 verdad este
esto ya lo vimos en el vídeo anterior
ahora qué hacemos ahora porque tenemos
atado aquí tener
justamente un carbono que está unido a
uno de los carbonos de nuestra molécula
verdad justamente por eso tiene
ramificación y de hecho recordemos que
esto implícitamente nos está diciendo
que tenemos tres hidrógenos verdad
entonces lo que tenemos aquí es
justamente como si fuera un metano un
metano pero unido a uno de los carbonos
de nuestra cadena verdad entonces
simplemente tenemos de este lado un
carbono un carbono
tenemos un carbono y eso nos va a decir
que bueno estarías correcto si piensas
que es meta algo verdad uno podría
pensar lo mejor es metano pero no es
metano justamente porque no está unido a
un hidrógeno pero el meta era el prefijo
para cuando tenemos un carbono entonces
la la terminación que le vamos a dar es
la verdad déjenme ponerlo con otro color
vamos a ponerle terminación y entonces
tenemos un metilo y la terminación y si
significa que se ramifica verdad se
ramifica de la cadena más larga se
ramifica de la cadena
más larga ok eso es porque es un grupo
alquiló los grupos alquilo son
justamente aquellos que parecen arcanos
pero en realidad son ramificaciones para
dejarlo digamos en términos prácticos ok
entonces vamos a ver otro ejemplo vamos
a ver no más bien antes de ver otro
ejemplo vamos a terminar de darle nombre
a esto verdad entonces podríamos decir
que es un metal no nano verdad metil no
nano
me tildó nano pero esto tiene ciertos
problemas por ejemplo si yo trato de
dibujar esta misma molécula
tenemos algo así
ok y tenemos esta ramificación de este
lado este sería nuestro metilo nano pero
qué pasaría por ejemplo si yo tengo algo
así si yo tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y de
aquí digamos del cuarto sale el el mismo
grupo verdad el mismo grupo metilo
entonces si te das cuenta para estas dos
moléculas aunque no aunque parecen
similares no son iguales justamente
donde se encuentra la ramificación y
ambos podrían llamarse metilo nano
entonces tenemos que idear nos una forma
para distinguir estos dos y lo que vamos
a hacer primero es enumerar los átomos
de la cadena o más bien los carbonos de
la cadena más larga de tal suerte que el
grupo ramificado el primero se encuentre
en el número más bajo aquí quiero decir
hay dos formas de enumerar esta cadena
verdad podría ser 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9 o
al revés
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 en este caso resultó
estar en el carbono 7 mientras que en el
sentido contrario está en el carbono 3
entonces vamos a enumerar justamente de
tal suerte que se encuentre en el menor
carbono que en este caso sería 3 verdad
4 5 6 7 8 y 9 entonces lo que tenemos es
justamente que ahora se encuentra este
este grupo metilo en el carbono 3 así
que vamos a denunciarlo justamente así
es el 3 metil no nano qué pasaría con el
otro caso si enumeramos de arriba a
abajo sería 1 2 3 4 5 6 está en el sexto
y si enumeramos de abajo para arriba
estaría en el 1 2 3 4 entonces nos
quedamos con esta enumeración 1 2 3
vamos
igual con verde 4
5 6 7 8 9 entonces concluimos que como
se llama esta molécula pues es el 4
metil 4 vamos a ponerlo con azul verdad
4 metil no nano verdad 4 metil no nano y
ya tenemos toda la información de estas
moléculas esta corresponde a esta área
que haga de de acá perdón mientras que
ésta corresponde a esta de aquí muy bien
entonces ya pudimos nombrar estas dos
moléculas ahora vámonos
en el sentido contrario digamos que
tenemos el nombre digamos que les doy el
2002 propio eta no muy bien tenemos el 2
propio y le está no entonces vamos a ir
desmenuzando este nombre primero termina
en a no eso significa que tiene enlaces
simples
enlaces simples verdad eso es porque es
un arcano ahora bien tenemos que el
prefijo f
eso significa 7 carbonos verdad la
cadena más larga va a tener 7 carbonos
ahora tenemos un grupo propio
tenemos un propio que significa el
propio y pues tenemos justamente un
grupo ramificado de 3 carbonos y
justamente se encuentra en el carbono 2
de nuestra cadena más larga entonces si
pintamos nuestra cadena más larga
déjenme pintar lo tendríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 ahí está este es el 1 el 2 el 3 el 4
el 5 el 6 y el 7 ahora nos dice que en
el en el 2 vamos a tener un grupo propio
verdad entonces podemos poner nuestro
propio y recordemos esto si hay que
memorizar nos que significa cada uno de
los de los prefijos verdad el propio si
empezamos en número
o enlistar los que teníamos en el vídeo
anterior teníamos para un carbono el met
para dos el et para tres el prop y para
cuatro el wood verdad entonces el propio
es de tres carbonos ahí lo tienen tres
carbonos y éste estará unido en el
carbono 2 entonces ya tenemos justamente
nuestro nuestra molécula que representa
al 2 propio eta no verdad vamos a ver
otro ejemplo digamos que ahora les les
doy el seis butil 6 butil tetra detrás
de acá no muy bien el 6 útil 3 tetra
decano nuevamente tenemos la terminación
a no eso significa que es un arcano y
que por lo tanto son puros enlaces en
simple es verdad ahora tenemos el tetra
tech de tradex era para 14 carbonos
entonces nuestra cadena más larga
nuestra cadena más larga va a ser de 14
carbonos entonces podemos ir pintando
eso tenemos 1
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 verdad
entonces tenemos 1 2
456 y aquí es en donde va a estar
nuestro grupo útil y ramificado verdad
déjenme terminar de enumerar los 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 y 14 muy bien entonces nos
dice que en el sexto carbono va a estar
un grupo útil vamos a poner este no sé
con rosa
el grupo útil lo podemos ver como una
ramificación de 4 carbonos algo así
entonces simplemente lo enlazamos books
lo dibujé muy lejos
a dibujar lo más cerca tenemos 1 2 3 4 y
simplemente lo enlazamos con el carbono
6 y ahí lo tienen nuestro 6 butil tetra
decano y ahora a lo mejor tú te estarías
o más bien te voy a hacer una pregunta
será posible que alguna vez me has
escrito el 9 útil tetra decano es decir
este mismo pero en vez de 6 ponerle 9 y
entonces tú dirás bueno a ver éste no
sepa a lo mejor podría ser algo por el
ejemplo algo por el estilo que sea aquí
nuestro útil verdad y esté unido al 9 y
entonces tú dirás pues sí y ahí lo
dibujaste porque no podría llover lo y
la respuesta es que no porque recordemos
que la nomenclatura tenemos que hacerla
en función de d
de que se encuentre en el menor número
posible cuando estamos enumerando verdad
que quiero decir con esto si yo tuviera
el un bueno déjenme hacerlo con otro
color
si yo enumerará con 1 2 3 4 5
78 y bueno así sucesivamente nos damos
cuenta que esta ramificación si
enumeramos al revés se encuentra en el
sexto verdad en el sexto entonces en
realidad nunca vamos a ver el nueve
butil tetra de decano porque en realidad
significa que estamos pensando en el
seis útil tetra decano verdad así que
sólo para resumir tenemos que recordar
que la iluminación de la cadena más
larga tiene que ser en en función de que
el grupo que se ramifica se encuentre en
el menor número posible en esta cadena